aujourd'hui c'est le jour où qu'on parle
de trois de plus regarde parce que je me
rende une juridiction en plus parce
qu'effectivement vous savez là c'est le
début de l'année on lan est déjà bien
commencé mais enfin c'est quand même
dans le début de l'année 2020 et on
regarde un petit peu tous les
smartphones qui vont sortir dans cette
année 2020 et notamment dans les
smartphones les plus attendus eh bien il
ya les nouveaux smartphones de one plus
il vous aura pas échappé comme le may 19
fois depuis sa sortie
deux modèles en même temps ça a surpris
pas mal de monde parce que ça changeait
vraiment par rapport à ceux visés
avant on a eu le one plus est le one
piece est pro et après deuxième semestre
de l'année on a eu le one + 7 t on plus
cet éperon way plus est des pros note
les rails edition qui caché ici dans
cette petite banane tout ça c'est bien
sympa tout c'est bien joli mais qu'est
ce qui va se passer en 2010 et bien
c'est super intéressant parce qu'en 2020
on devrait pas en arriver un modèle
comme les années précédentes
pas deux modèles comme l'année dernière
mais peut-être trois modèles au moins
deux plus vite on inclut suite ou un an
+8 il ait ce serait vraiment différent
par rapport à ta fille la marque après
la marque a continué d'évoluer
je ne sais pas si vous suivez un petit
peu m'en fait one + s'est fait connaître
vraiment avec le one plus one au début
on près d'une grosse communauté parce
que selon être plus il manque
effectivement un produit le produit d'y
aller l'umq reouven plus continue
d'évoluer
d'année en année jusqu'à être
aujourd'hui un acteur extrêmement
important du monde de la téléphonie
mobile
et ça c'est vachement intéressant alors
moi j'ai beaucoup la marque j'ai utilisé
pendant très longtemps le one + 7 pro
l'année dernière j'allais utiliser plein
d'autres messieurs hd beaucoup plus
utilisés pendant plusieurs mois et je
trouve vraiment cool très bon produit
belle finition on a un excellent rapport
qualité-prix produit vraiment vraiment
choix qui répond vraiment à plaindre
problématique le grand écran caméra pop
up c'est rigolo
la caméra marche bien extrêmement
performant ball est enfin là moi j'aime
beaucoup
donc on continue dans les années où est
plus contenu sans différents modèles
toussa toussa toussa
jusque là ça marche tout va bien on
connait on comprend l'histoire l'année
dernière où en plus ça vraiment vraiment
bousculé les codes en sortant deux
smartphones comme je le disais mais où
est plus qu une petit peu se démarquer
on retrouve notamment à la fnac et on
commence effectivement à retrouver la
marque chez les opérateurs donc le code
100% internet
tout ça ça évolue mais ça c'est normal
parce que si vous voulez là marc grosy
et en grossissant la marque doit
effectivement est présente de plus en
plus il ya besoin de conquérir n'est pas
un marché a besoin de ça mais par
rapport à la concurrence mais il ya pas
mal de besoin jusque là ça semble plutôt
logique donc on n'a plus regardé moins
sage vous sorti c'est très cool à roanne
plus là
ça fait plutôt coup donc on devrait
avoir trois médailles or c'est marrant
parce que c'est de définir un petit peu
le portrait robot de ces trois modèles
si vous regardez un peu si on prend un
coup dans ce qu'on attend pour toutes
les rumeurs dans toutes les fuites
eh bien ça nous annonce qu'en fait il ya
un truc qui partirait en tout cas pas un
bénéfice qui partiraient ses bénéfices
du très grand écran sans encoches sans
rien puisqu'en trouverez un petit
poisson pour le one + 8 une bulle un
double point sur un double caméra mais
toujours sous forme de bulles sur le wan
plus une pro est effectivement une
petite caméra qu'un petit point sont
aussi au milieu par contre cette fois ci
sur le web +8 light sur les dogues se
sont déportés sur le côté gauche alors
mon sur le principe les petits points
sont pourquoi pas mais en fait mon truc
qui me chagrine un peu si cette rumeur
est avérée c'est vrai avoir un pouvoir
avec des pincettes mais tous semblent en
tout cas aller dans ce sens là c'est que
je trouve qu'avec le one + 7 pro et les
délais caméra pop up en plus à faire
vrai pas en avant dans ok on propose un
grand écran quad hd complètement libéré
d'encoches de rien du tout donc en
termes de gaming en terme d'expérience
de visionnage de série de films tout ce
que vous voulez c'est vraiment en moi
c'est vraiment un des points forts en
tout cas de smartphones en plus du côté
90 à face à moi je trouve ça vraiment
vraiment vraiment bien et j'aurais du
mal à comprendre que one plus en 2020
revienne en arrière juste du point de
vue esthétisme de leur smart est
effectivement pourrait me dire ils
reviennent pas en arrière c'est
peut-être quelque chose de bien intégrer
ni intégrés moi je sais pas je sais pas
je serai prêt du but à 6 à tulle après
il faut pas oublier qu'il n'ya pas très
longtemps au cis je vous emmener avec
moi las vegas ils ont tout simplement
présenter une nouvelle technologie avec
un verre est trop chromatique qui vient
cacher la petite caméra pour la faire
apparaître lorsque vous allez active est
tout simplement l'appareil photo est ce
que ça sera intégrée à ces nouveaux one
+ 8 où elle plus huit pros et pourquoi
pas besoin de +8 like that more est
vraiment avoir un sens de la loire cette
manière là c'est à dire qu'en fait on
garderait cet écran complètement
décomplexé on garde cet écran sans en
poche
et lorsque vous activez briller votre
caméra il vous n'auriez pas de caméra
pop up vous aurez votre caméra qui
apparaîtrait là ça pour moi ce serait la
meilleure solution est là il bleus
feraient tout le monde est là
banco je signe tout de suite si par
contre on se retrouve avec un poinçon
qui apparaît tout le temps même lorsque
vous aller allumer votre écran en tout
cas c'est ce que semble suggérer les
les rumeurs les quelques clichés qui
circulent sur le net voilà moi je suis
un petit peu embêté avoir ça on se
reverra par contre franck est vachement
bien ce qu effectivement ou une puce a
annoncé avoir un écran 120 hertz
donc on aura c'est une certitude sur le
wan +8 et le web plus fluide promouvoir
sur le monde plus vite light peut-être
un écran 90e de ce côté là
comme ce qu'on avait sur ce modèle a été
déjà vachement bien on aurait un écran
120 hertz sur ces deux modèles et des
modèles les plus haut de gamme et ça
croyez moi c'est bien parce que ça prend
vraiment d'une confort visuel lorsque
vous allez dire scrollé lorsque vous
allez dire jouer à des jeux ça apporte
beaucoup de confort beaucoup de fidélité
et ça c'est vraiment bien pour améliorer
l'expérience de navigation l'expérience
de gainey expérience de visionnage tout
simplement
donc on va effectivement ce portrait
robot qui commence à dessiner
smartphones haut de gamme smartphone
très haut de gamme avec un superbe écran
on restera toujours sur des dalles super
amoled dédale fabriqué par samsung c'est
ce qu'on trouve pour l'instant chez one
piece et je pense qu'on va continuer
l'année prochaine là dessus on serait
sûr modèle le plus gamme avec un écran
quad hd
c'est ce qu'on avait l'année dernière
sur le moins de plus cette pro au
quotidien installé là dessus à voir sur
le wan +8
est ce qu'on aura un écran full hd quad
hd bon à voir
je pense que par contre on aura un écran
full hd sur le wan +8 kleitz
effectivement un jour -votre jour sur le
wan plus suite on pourra avoir des crocs
de 6,5 pouces 6 7 pouces sur le modèle
professionnel et peut-être 6,4 pouces
quelque chose comme ça entre 6 2 6 4
pouces sur le web +8 light
alors maintenant je bosse sur la
question ces petites caméras peut pas le
dire bien puisqu'en fait si loin de plus
vous arrêter de caméras pop il peut y
avoir deux raisons principales la
première raison c'est qu'il ya des
problèmes techniques à cannes et un pop
up ne fonctionne pas à le faire entrer
des cochonneries des grains de sable
décidé ça et du coup ils ont un retour
négatif j'ai beaucoup de mal à y croire
moi je l'utilisé pendant plusieurs mois
et j'ai jamais eu aucun problème avec la
caméra populaire alors effectivement il
n'ya pas certification ip 68 2 par la
caméra pop up mais le smartphone malgré
tout et résistant à l'eau et à la
poussière
je ne crois pas que le sujet de
problèmes je serais quand même
relativement surpris de ce côté là
le deuxième point et non des moindres
c'est qu'il faudrait gagner un petit peu
de place à l'intérieur parce que cette
année ça serait une petite révolution
pour une plus il se pourrait que la
recharge sans fil
arrive enfin enfin enfin je mets des
guillemets quand je dis en face votre
puce en fait foi le pousse à toujours
dit nous on va pas sortir de recharge
sans fil on n'est pas convaincu
aujourd'hui par le réel intérêt que moi
parce que les recharges sont quand même
relativement lente
pour avoir une recharge plus rapide ça
pourrait avoir un sens c'est peut-être
que one plus se positionnerait dessus
cette année en 2020 donc il faudrait
gagner de la place à l'intérieur donc
enlever ce petit module pop up pour que
c'est un peu les murs et pouvoir
intégrer cette techno sont trop de
problèmes ça pourrait être une raison de
notre côté venir ajouter une petite
caméra prostré dans l'écran lorsque vous
regardez tout le temps tout ça au profit
de la recharge sans fil
j'ai un petit peu de mal au seuil droits
sur les modèles one + 8 est bonne
puisque huit pros en aurait un écran
incurvé tandis que sur le modèle lite on
aurait un écran je peux aussi vous le
savez mais one piece baisse depuis
longtemps sur l'a5 j'ai donc ça serait
pas surprenant qu'on retrouve des
modèles complètement 5g cette fois ci
pas un modèle option n'est en aucun cas
un mois de plus 5 g je pense
effectivement le one piece fuite et de
one + 8 pro intégreront directement la
scène jack qui va se déployer de plus en
plus en 2020 et dans les années à venir
en cherchant toujours aller plus loin en
termes de connectivité à mon avis on
aura également sur le modèle
professionnel du wifi 6 pour ce qu'on
oublie toujours plus rapidement en
fibres profiter d'un meilleur débit
internet ça ça me paraît quand même
relativement logique l'ouest face à
toujours oxygène os qui est une des
meilleure surcouche actuellement sur
android qui tournerait sur un android 10
alors au niveau de la can et un synthé
être parce que si vous regardez un petit
peu ce qui se profile du côté des
quelques bancs tous amis du côté des
rumeurs édifice on voit a priori que sur
le web plus huit pros on aurait quatre
capteurs à l'aria alors un capteur
principal qui pourrait à mon avis on n'a
pas de chiffres exacts mais moi je
parierais vraiment sur un capteur de
plus de 100 méga pixels pourquoi pas 100
8 mégapixels parce que tout ça va
tourner sur un processeur snapdragon 865
pas d'intégrer des caméras jusqu'à 200
mégapixels ou en plus c'est toujours fer
de lance en termes de technologie donc
j'imagine très clairement qu'à dessus
ils vont bien vous proposer ce qui se
fait de mieux en terme de faute au sens
8 mégapixels grand minimum sur le modèle
professionnel ont constaté les objectifs
en or effectivement un ultra grand-angle
et honorer la caméra t'offre time of
light pour venir vraiment mesuré pour
mode portrait ça vient de mesurer moi ce
n'est calculée par rapport à
l'arrière-plan et ça ne détache
complètement pour faire des fous que ce
soit en vidéo ce soit en photo
complètement optimisé
jusque là ça serait la base ensuite le
deuxième modèle qui serait pas
professionnel on enlèverait probablement
la caméra top et technocentre un petit
peu long terme de pixels sur la caméra
principale peut-être en 64 me à pixel
avoir parce que sans le modèle lite on
aurait soit deux capteurs soit trois
capteurs peut-être de capteurs avec une
caméra de 48 mégapixels un téléobjectif
peut-être un ultra grand angle à voir ce
qui pourrait vraiment essayé de ce côté
là en tout cas sur le modèle pro on voit
qu'on a deux caméras pour nourrir ses
pas pour l'instant signé pourquoi pas en
aurait deux caméras à l'avant
j'imagine une caméra principal client du
très grand temps pour pousser un petit
peu les murs que vous avez plein de
potes vous voulez faire un cette fille
avec un volume en arrière pourquoi pas
tandis que ce sont les deux autres on
aurait une seule caméra d'un évidemment
prince ans un petit peu compliqué de
venir spéculer en terme de ce peuple là
dessus et justement puisqu'on parle de
photos est ce qu'on aura à l'arrière
cette technologie avec le verre est trop
chromatique c'est à dire la caméra qui
disparaît complètement ce que je vous ai
montré sur le concept one qui était
présenté en partenariat avec mclaren
ou alors est ce qu'ils se disent ok
cette techno elle est là elle existe on
la garde pour un peu plus tard on
voulait sortira peut-être au deuxième
semestre puisque s'était montrée sur un
modèle en partenariat avec mclaren on
pourrait très bien imaginer un one + 8
et pro mac line edition avec cette
techno ça aurait un sens en tout cas de
plus un peu plus ça sur le deuxième
semaine de l'année 2020 je vous le dis
au terme de perforer dessin dragon 865
quasiment partout peut-être une petite
rumeur qui circule sans modèle light où
on peut retrouver à processeurs de chez
mediatek jeu pas persuadé mais à voir on
aurait effectivement entre 8 à 12 giga
drame minimum 100 étudiants de stockage
imagine 128 256 et pourquoi pas 512 dans
la plus grosse config
bien évidemment non extensible
connaissant voix de plus on a toujours
des haut parleurs stéréo pour une
meilleure immersion toujours pas de
prise jack et honorer une batterie entre
4500 à 5000 milliards eur soit le modèle
pro on peut imaginer une 4510 opérant
sur le moins de +8 et une batterie de
4000 milan paire eur / modèle light
caisse covan plus pour nous propose en
termes de tarif là dessus j'imagine
clairement qu'ils vont rester dans la
même idée de ce qu'il propose un one + 8
un petit peu moins de 600 euros 599
seront restaurés dans l'adn de la marque
un modèle professionnel un peu plus de
700 euros pourquoi pas 759 pourra
toujours un coup dans l'idée est un
modèle un peu moins cher un modèle nike
pourrait en tout cas si on spécule à peu
dans cette idée là venir flirter avec
les 400 50 480 euros ça pourrait avoir
un sens si vous êtes plus garde son
calendrier tout ça sera présenté au mois
de mai 2020 dans tous les cas restez
connectés abonnez-vous ce pas déjà le
cas activer la cloche parce qu'on en
reparlera en parlera doivent aller
vous parlez de votre plus parce que
j'aime beaucoup la marque elle innove
elle propose des produits vachement
intéressante très complet à des prix
défiant toute concurrence est là ont pu
cette année on est plus à frapper très
fort aux crs 2020 en montrant cette
techno complètement inédite avec le
verrait les troncs chromatique ça je
trouve ça vraiment bien donc rester
connecté on en reparlera dites moi vous
ce que vous attendez des nouveaux
smartphones de bonnes plus qu'est ce qui
pourrait vous intéresser qu est ce que
vous pensez quoi de plus beau
représenter en 2020 est-ce que vous
pensez que cette idée du verre
effectivement qui disparaît la caméra
qui disparaît grâce au baryton
chromatique est ce que vous pensez que
ça va intégrer dès le début d'année dès
le lancement du windows 8
ou alors plus tard à la fin de l'année
mark et moi tout ça bien évidemment on
va en commentant quant à nous on reste
connectés parce qu'on reparle de votre
plus très prochainement
il ya plein de belles histoires à
raconter il ya plein de choses à
raconter personnellement j'aime beaucoup
la marque j'aime beaucoup ce travail qui
feront j'aime beaucoup et innovation
censée nous embrassons rendez vous dès
demain pour continuer à parler tech à
demain
nicky hayden
devinez quoi
[Musique]